hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to another lot of their tip ok
so today we're gonna talk about
libraries and by libraries I really mean
libraries and game engines so and so
like that but uh don't become more
apparent as we begin ok so first of all
what libraries am I even talking about
so for Java we've got libraries like l w
GL the lightweight java game library
very very popular libgdx selectivity and
of course the actual Java library so
first of all just skim through this so l
w jz l why should you even use LW j GL
and well there's a lot of reasons first
of all it uses OpenGL ok it is
essentially a binding of OpenGL for Java
because of course OpenGL is written in C
and FML Dobie JJ is basically uses the
Java native interface J and I to to
enable you to access that C code inside
Java so in other words it's still
running C code but inside Java okay
that's essentially what although LW j GL
lets you do run opengl which is written
and safe now
it also includes things like like like
loading textures actually I think that's
more of us like you tell thing to do it
uh but it does include things like
keyboard input and the actual window so
it creates a window for you and
everything and there's a display and you
can do full screen and solve that it
even grabs the mouse and does it does
awesome stuff like that that would take
you a lot longer to do manually so on
it's more than just an OpenGL binding
like say Java jet joggle I think it is
Jo GL JA for OpenGL
I haven't put that on this list by the
way Jo jail but just because I've ever
used it so I can't really talk about it
but as far as l wgl goes it's much more
than just opengl for java it's it's like
a whole it's it's a lightweight java
game library so it is a game library but
it's fairly fit fairly lightweight it
doesn't have any any specific things
that's a lot to you so in other words
you know it's not an engine or anything
you still have to make your own engine
in LW j GL if you want to be able to use
it but um but it you know some of the
stuff is already done for you which is
also which is well awesome
so lib jdx really really good ok really
good now that is more of an engine I put
it into libraries and engines you'll see
later but it is more of an engine but it
does include awesome features like well
being able to pretty much output too
mobile device and you can make a game in
Java and it will just simply you'd
literally just compile it normally and
it will actually run on the iOS and
Android and all of that it's really
really awesome in fact I think it also
supports html5 which is crazy there's
libs libgdx is just it's one of the best
ways to make a game in Java if you're
running out of time I guess as well as
even if you're not really really easy to
use really awesome thing but it is more
of an engine in the library so yeah yeah
select today I don't like selected a
very much I just don't like the way they
kind of do things I prefer to just use L
WHL to write my own thing a slick 2d and
lob JGL are basically made by the same
kind of people kind of but select it is
essentially uses it uses L dubba jgl
okay so it does use opengl it is
hardware accelerated and it is very good
now the Java library okay that is the
important one that I've pretty much been
using for all past loving bears I really
like writing stuff from scratch ok
that's just who I am
I just like doing it I don't know why
it's fun to me it's actually more fun
for me to make an engine than to make a
bit of a game I don't know that kind of
sounds you know not really in the spirit
of what I'm there but that's kind of
that's just who I am I can't I can't
help that I really like the technical
stuff like dealing with color color
spacing in colors and some of that and
you know a bit shifting that's I really
like that stuff so the Java library is
great for that because the way that I
usually make games with the Java library
is it's using an array of pixels right
and then I then I can just manipulate
each of those pixels I can change the
color of each of those pixels and thus I
can create different images now that's
not all you can do okay you can just
directly display images handling
keyboard input in java is a breeze
creating a window in java is a breeze
creating a graphics spreading a
rectangle that you can move around the
screen is really really easy okay
so um you know in java what you what you
do have essentially is the opportunity
to just use what is already in java to
make something that to make a game okay
so again you will have to put work into
it though that's the other thing with
something like lwg else look today not
100% sure about today I'm very
than that but in a large AGL and in
normal Java you will have to ride an
engine for yourself libgdx I'm pretty
sure you won't have to
I'll live JD actually won't have to
selectivity I'm not sure about that okay
so let's talk about say plus plus now
now say plus plus is very different
because he doesn't have that Java
library that enables you to create
windows handle input put graphics some
of the screen easily it doesn't have
much doesn't have any of that okay you
have to write that's up from scratch so
um that's why it's pretty much
imperative to use library if you wanna
make a game and said let's loss now what
library should choose I pretty much
ordered it from best to worst they're
not best to worse the best of I guess
most useful to let's least useful in my
opinion here so uh
SDL simple directmedia layer brutally
int okay runs and boats okay whether you
know DirectX or OpenGL STL will have
your card make sure you use if you do
you if you do end up using STL make sure
you grab STL two which is the which is
the good version STL one is I think it's
might not even be hardware accelerated
anyway there's a bunch of different
versions but the point is SDL toe is the
one you want it's what it supports both
OpenGL and DirectX so whatever API
you're you know I guess rolling with you
can do it now it also supports um
essentially like it can basically blip
canvases as well so and what are they
call surfaces so uh it can do the pixel
right thing it is a bit slower than
javis version but it can still do it one
thing I should probably mention quickly
about Java as well is its Santa Java
library that's not really hardware
accelerated ok you can another of
volatile images and you can kind of just
know basically Java isn't hardware so
alright it was slick to a libgdx and El
Topo Gigio are okay with mentioning now
in say plus plus all these a hardware
slaughter I did okay STL includes much
more than gistic OpenGL context includes
an entire la game engine almost okay you
still have to make your own engine but
pretty much the method calls you'll be
pulling are already there for you okay
so it does have input handling it does
have stuff like Mouse grabbing it does
have what's that other things an
important thing that have had oh yes
image loading and
decrypting and sly that it does have um
it does have you you you can actually
get something called STL image which
will let you load PNG JPEG and just so
it has all that stuff okay GL FW on the
other hand is literally just an OpenGL
context okay so GL fw allows you to use
opengl in c++ in a window it creates a
window for you which runs opengl that's
basically what your left over he does he
does include input handling as well but
at its core I guess it's just basically
in OpenGL context now in gfw you know
unlike SDL here it doesn't have any kind
of image loading capabilities so you
have to basically download the jpg and
PNG libraries yourself okay s FML I
haven't used that it's essentially kind
of like GL of W it's OpenGL as well and
can it's it's okay it's basically an
OpenGL engine kind of it's got calls to
stuff like shaders that you don't have
to set up yourself so it is cool like
that GL FW is literally just allowing
you to use opengl inside a window as the
sfm ELLs a bit more than that and
allegro finally is also a pretty solid
choice that's been around for a long
time which I again haven't used but
heard good things about so those are
your choices okay what I'm gonna pick in
this light um there is since I've
already picked probably going to use
Java in let them in this lot um they're
just because um just because of the
development time if you guys haven't
seen me comparison of programming
languages I made which was the previous
tip there'll be a link in the
description probably an annotation right
there if I don't forget to put it up and
essentially you'll probably see it in
related videos it's just called a lot of
their tips programming languages okay so
go go watch that but essentially Java is
a lot a lot faster for development then
um so as far as if you have like 48
hours here so um but out of out of those
libraries I'm probably gonna use ether
LW j GL the standard like a Java library
depending on what the fame is and what
my ideas are okay let's talk about
development environments because that's
really important especially for you
people who maybe aren't as comfortable
with programming and conscious make
games in seconds essentially so we have
unity okay
unity is a big one it's very very
popular in both the real world and in
love and their lot and a lot of games
are made with that unity now the great
thing about unity right that I really
like is it has a web player kind of
thing right
it essentially runs inside a web browser
can run inside a web browser which is
awesome I should probably mention
actually let's go back a bit that uh
obviously all the Java stuff is
cross-platform and all the C++ stuff
that I've listed is also cross-platform
so you'll be fine with that
okay but it won't run inside a web
browser ah okay so there's a few let me
just know not default okay so we've got
um we've got yeah so the great thing
about unity is that it can run you know
unity can run inside a web browser which
means that as I talked about in the
previous tip as well in the program and
I just wanted it's really beneficial for
all of them there because more people
will play a game just because they don't
have to download it so unity is a really
solid choice if you don't stay sharp
I'd be going for that and maybe just
because I personally don't like the
offerings the c-sharp has in terms of
engines and stuff like that I don't like
how it deals with OpenGL I just I don't
know it's just not my thing
so I would probably go for using
something like unity as well the fact
that it'll if you're making a 3d game
I'm gonna be honest with you guys
Unity's probably gonna be the best way
to do it in 48 hours
okay it's gonna give you the most
visually impressive impressive game I
mean like getting a perspective down
show that's easy but stuff like lighting
that it supports that that that's really
really good it's really hard to do from
scratch in something like Eldo BL w GL
because you'll have to write shaders and
all that stuff so unity is a really top
choice game maker um first game I ever
made in my life was made with game maker
in 2006 so uhm gammak is solid at least
it was seven years ago more seven and a
half years ago um
but game maker is again a pretty good
choice I know it's got a lot of it it
does have a lot of advanced things
because there's actually a game called
spelunky that I used to play about two
years ago as well that was made with
game maker so in other words that pretty
much proves to me that game makers
really solid because that is a top game
okay spelunky look it up W I think
there's a newer version
now that wouldn't be made with care
maker but the the original one was that
was made by one person so again make
against other choice it's a whole
interface it's a whole development
environment so that'll really speed up
stuff because you won't have to program
as much you left - um well yeah and also
you have advanced debugging tools as
well in something like unity Unreal
Engine okay UDK I now um
CryEngine is also a good one I'm pretty
sure that's proprietary Unreal Engine I
think is as I think it is as well I know
a few people were using it full of them
there don't know how that panned out but
um
Unreal Engine again is a really good one
if you're looking for something to do
with 3d and kind of I guess first person
shooter ish like okay or just crunchy
textures that's what I think of so
engines that those were development
environments they're also known as
engines of course but for Java we've got
Jay monkey engine which is a 3d engine
pretty good I'm not a big fan of it but
it does work and is really good for what
well for 3d pretty much libgdx I've put
this into engines as well just because
it is a bit of an engine isn't it like
it allows you to basically it's got like
it's it's pretty fun a lot of the code
for you already so I kind of consider it
half and in half library are probably
the only reason I consider the libraries
if I had it's also a blip which types of
libraries so yeah
so again libgdx is kind of like in fact
it says kind of engine on the screen
here but it really probably is kind of a
library and definitely an engine for
safe as possible got a lift and I'll go
both 3d engine is really good if again
if you're looking for something to do
with a 2d engine the I would just write
my own okay that's not gonna take you
too long probably will but again you
know use libraries like Allegro and
stuff like that that will help you out a
lot if you're looking for if you're
looking for 2d stuff essentially alright
so why why on earth would you use a
library
why not just write everything from
scratch well guys I'm gonna be
completely asked with you guys time bro
time
you have 48 hours you do not want to
waste an hour writing a key input
handler okay you want to waste that hour
not waste wisely spend that hour
actually making your game why not design
an enemy and it or an entity system well
why not why not feat why not
the graph is for a menu instead of
freaking figuring out how to make a
window okay big difference you have to
really prioritize what you're gonna be
doing here okay honestly time is of the
essence when it comes to love them their
game not engine you are enlightened
they're most likely to make a game not a
game engine big difference there is a
there is such a massive difference
between a game and a game engine okay
a game engine supports the creation of
games whereas the game you just go ahead
and make the game okay you know what
this is the more I'm saying this the
more that's actually kind of in my head
connecting to what I said yesterday
about um about about the like the the
job of a full machine versus suppose
balls native code making a game is like
using native curtain like using a native
language and or native programming I
guess and an engine is kind of like
using a virtual machine programming kind
of thing okay virtual machine
development so in a game when you're
making a game you're correct you're like
connecting you know the application
communicates directly to the processor
kind of like a native language does
whereas we're making an engine you know
your application communicates to the
virtual machine which then communicates
to the to the to the what am I saying to
the processor okay so in other words
that little metaphor now is panning out
that when you're making a game you are
programming your entry when you're
making an engine you're programming what
you're programming the pitstop which
will be on the way of you making your
game which will be your entry so in
other words you're just creating a third
wheel instead of just sticking with two
so make sure that you make a game not an
engine don't worry about handling really
cool stuff and advanced clipping
everywhere especially if you're running
so if you're writing stuff from scratch
just focus on making a game and that's
why a library is really important
because all of that code that is there
to make yourself an engine it's all bets
there so you can just focus on the game
which is I think really the important
part of what I'm there you want to make
again on an engine less probable stress
okay so you will probably have less
stress if you make a game and on an
engine because stuff will work more game
alright more game you
we'll be making your game will be better
if you've already got an engine for it
just gonna put it that way okay the
gameplay will be you'll spend more time
on the gameplay you'll spend more time
on the graphics on the assets everything
that's why you know it's really
important to just make the game and not
an engine okay if you use the library
again you will make more of a game than
if you make if you write something from
scratch less problems okay
a lot of the time you'll run into
problems problems you have no idea why
they're happening and but they are okay
and when you are under that kind of
pressure where you only have 48 oh you
might be like 4 hours left we'll finish
you decide to add a feature cause you're
an idiot and and then suddenly that
facial breaks the entire game you figure
out that all okay that's actually
happening because the way I write the
engine was literally stupid because I
was rushing it okay so yeah use the
library okay really really important
that's pretty much it guys
alright so you know just in conclusion
libraries will help you develop your
game faster okay they will they will
help you avoid writing an engine
because after all of them there is about
running games not entrance so I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of live in
today's hips I guess and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye tomorrow actually
I'll see you guys tomorrow bye